hum
[Música]
[Aplausos]
roubaram-nos os substitutos disponíveis
o confronto que os momentos desde a copa
de 1970 nós somos lima 10 transplantes
da esquerda recuperou ontem no olímpico
não não sou feliz
aliás este foi nosso quartel-general se
foi nossa não ser o corte tanto na rádio
como eu sei que nós queremos dizer ao
mundo inteiro a selecção vai ser bonito
entre nós porque estamos a tratar as
coisas com ele e estamos bastante
significante em termos de opções
portanto é nosso por tim já os dois
setores antes que estão todos muito
bonito e é que nós vamos conseguir mas
nós somos uma banda com bateria o mais
comum de ensinar a história como
acontece na loja de vez na posição e
conseguimos um tubo dinâmico de
panelinha de francisco louçã
fé e risco voltar às raízes anti lula
tinha programado uma bandeira do santos
no ano 2000 e ficamos sozinhos na sala
mensais e tivemos que ampliar
então face temos que tomar a cosworth
que entretanto é mas hoje vamos misturar
as três primeiras músicas que nós
quisemos nos três primeiros meses né
a ponte vermelha que as persianas
eu vi os erros joão grandino as
condições estão combinados como lançar
neste primeiro ano mas vão torcer é mais
bons
não espero que o nosso baterista é que
eu posso é esse o problema
isto é uma experiência única do mercado
assim o jogo truncado nervoso quando
jogo
[Música]
eu tirei um ano e jovens são mais
meninos
[Música]
a roupa
ae
o dinheiro
sete chances
s a
o futebol
ai ai ai
absurdo
[Música]
o que quero é grande
o dinheiro
olha se eu andar de baixo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
doc douro de sol
cambridge
o tcheco
[Música]
t
[Aplausos]
tenho um amigo bicho das flores a rolar
oeste quilombo é como fazer um ok tinha
uma inteligência porque a equipe está
bem foi um dos nossos melhores ligas
[Música]
agora o quinto mais rápido hoje temos
comentar que está havendo intenção é o
fim do caminho
[Aplausos]
futebol
[Música]
[Aplausos]
os filhos mais visitada espanha
austrália em torno ao sol que surgiu de
a formula one minute adam silver de 11
dias
vou fazer continuar respeitando se o
vídeo não do interior tesouro tomou
posse para imprimir a empregar pelo
vírus foi campeão nas provas de vida de
nossa equipe que conquista
che não queria que as pessoas também se
cruzam com os concertos de música pois é
totalmente proibida chan
inspirada nas noites e madrugadas por
lixo que ele tenha mais acionado chelsea
o euro
[Aplausos]
[Música]
em 2011
s
ae
[Música]
sim senhor
o santos espera fechar o ano crescendo
aí é bom jogar
to
ae
outra coisa funciona
o giro
fui eu
[Música]